we don't care
um
foreign
thank you very much
Evan I'm sorry
we have anyone out here
hi David sir you want me to shut off no
you can keep recording we just need to
make sure that no one else comes in here
that's not authorized
[Music]
like for folks coming in yeah okay all
right just stay here for right now okay
yes sir thank you
[Applause]
what's that are you coming in for yeah
uh press I'm live right now on TED Talk
is covered in the governor okay thank
you
appreciate you
foreign
[Music]
we were up there we had a live shot
scheduled to record at 5 15. okay that's
locked in stone so Coincidence of all
coincidence the governor literally walks
out at 5 50. it's the worst possible
timing in the world okay but we can
there's nothing that we can do about
that he's he's committed to doing his
live show he's got people talking to him
he doesn't know about whether he needs
to talk about it
let me let me let me stop it yeah let me
stop you I'm just I'm so reason why I
understand that the reason why he is
where he is he was told to leave he
refused to leave okay then the building
superintendent comes over and says I
don't want you here okay
I can't speak to that that's what I just
I thought I might just be able to give
you some insight on I understand from
myself I understand you guys have a job
it's just I get it but but when you're
told to step out and you can get to the
point where the building
superintendent's coming over and saying
you need to leave
thank you